because i feel like there's not a lot of
music coming out that is very relatable
that people are very vulnerable on that
are like honest
and you're very honest on this body work
talk about this caught on camera record
huh no one asked me about that one yeah
yeah the caught on camera record that
now i i listened to it and
did you get caught on camera [ __ ]
some some somebody what what is this
record about um
caught on camera um
is like the catalyst for my breakup yeah
okay so what happened so you just i mean
listen you put it on the album so we you
know yeah um
yeah she just like saw some [ __ ] so you
got caught on camera doing something
like a was it like a sex tape or was it
like you know you're out and somebody is
put you on the story and you're with a
[ __ ] on this you know that happens like
yes to both of those so it was a sex
tape and that
um
uh
yeah
damn man you're a wild boy
how did it happen wait
did someone well did you have like let's
break down this oh no
was the sex tape on your phone or did
someone send it to her
did i already confirm that was a sex
tape i feel like i didn't even do that
you just did you said yes to both
[Laughter]
um
i don't like subscribe to this by the
way um but
at that point in my life
um it was just so much new [ __ ] going on
and like what i've learned about
like what i've learned about something
in me is like when my life
is fast and there's a lot of exciting
[ __ ] it's it's moving um it's like a lot
of like crazy shows and crazy
experiences
um
i always try to like match that energy
with some [ __ ] i always try to because
it's like when you get fit because i've
been like
i've had really highs like really big
highs
like i probably lived more than
i should have with this level of fam i'm
at because like i feel like only people
know me is like my fans right now but
i've lived like a lot of [ __ ] has gone
on so
so
you know i've i've done [ __ ] where it's
like you
if you haven't lived it it it i think
it's just kind of hard to understand but
when these big highs of like performing
and everybody like needing something
from you
um it's
it's very quick to
for me at least to feel very low
afterward like i've had like shows where
it's like the highest i've ever been and
then i get in the tour bus i just cry or
i just like go in my go to the bathroom
and just like be so down
so
what the only thing that like
makes that
makes that going from here to going from
here like
what i tried to do in my life is like
stay the [ __ ] up there with some [ __ ]
and that just makes you make decisions
that are like
not within your character you know so i
think at this point
like i know how to balance it a little
more
the difference is back then i felt very
like
my eyes were so big like like the last
project the last project i'm like whoa
like this girl thinks this and and you
got groupies now
and this money or female fans that are
willing to show you how appreciative of
your music they are but whatever even
it is like you know like whatever not
for sure for sure and i was like
i treated every famous person i met it
was like this is i gotta take advantage
of this opportunity this is so much
bigger than me now
i feel like
i belong here this is what i'm this is
what my this is
it doesn't feel so far-fetched anymore
if this was an interview where i was
doing this like
three years ago i would be nervous i'd
be like make sure you come across the
right way now i don't really give a [ __ ]
because i know i'm here for like me like
this is probably the first time like
this press [ __ ] i'm doing that my
friends are gonna watch these interviews
and they're going to be like that's my
favorite yourself yeah
the last one the the i mean i don't
really watch my old interviews but i
have a feeling like my friends would be
like oh i see what he's doing he's
trying to like do his business he's
trying like but now it's just like i i
don't i know i'm here to be me so i'm
just be me that's how i'm really going
to survive that's how i'm really going
to last because i can rewrite history i
can i can try to recreate history and
rap and go viral i know what it's like
to go viral i know what it is
do that i've done it i've seen what it
does it's cool for a week
but if it's not you it it doesn't feel
as good as you think it does what feels
good is this album and even if it
doesn't do what i wanted to do but if
there's some people who say like bro i
love that song that's like someone
saying i love you
that's what it feels like so i feel so
much better now i just feel like because
you're like this this album is me this
is this is my life right now yeah i have
nothing high like that's dope man